i have the most outrageous clip for you
from this judge bruce schroeder
schroeder schrader everybody tells me a
different every time i pronounce it one
way i get an email saying it's the other
one so i'll say schreider kind of a
middle middle ground on him um in the
kyle rittenhouse trial
talking about when he had a black in his
jury
it's you know there's there are things
about this guy that we could say are
relevant to the case substantively that
we are concerned with and there's things
about this guy that just make him seem
kind of like a wacky guy and what this
is about is the fact that on the day
that the jury started deliberating and
as of this moment the jury continues to
deliberate into day three about the five
charges against kyle rittenhouse the
judge you had a pool of 18 jurors
and they all watched all of the
testimony and looked at all of the
evidence but only 12 actually
participate in the deliberations so on
the first day of deliberations they had
to choose six of the 18 to serve as
alternates meaning they stay at the
courthouse day after day without
deliberating in case
anything happens to the 12 jurors that
are actually taking part in the
deliberation the way they selected the
six to come out is they had a tumbler
almost like if you had like a lottery
and they tumbled the names pieces of
paper with the juror numbers on them and
they actually had kyle rittenhouse reach
in and select the six people that would
be removed from the 18. and a lot of
people in the media thought that was
weird why it's almost like a game show
why is kyle rittenhouse himself doing it
and the judge has a perfectly reasonable
explanation which is
there have been times in the past
where
when it wasn't
when when we were doing it when it was
the clerk for example doing it you would
have an outcome that raised eyebrows
like for example
the
one black potential juror being the one
that is removed and it's like oh my
goodness it looks like racial bias so
the judge explains that in order to
prevent that he says well we'll just let
the defendant do it so that we can't be
accused of hand-picking juries based on
race or any other features but
he bizarrely in telling the story says
that when they did this once
what came up was a black the black and
it just is so odd to hear him talk this
way take a look at this
it was a big case i think it was a
murder case but i'm not sure
um and there were there was a black
defendant
and there were 13 jurors one of whom was
black
and when the
clerk the clerk the government official
drew the name out of the tumbler
it was a black
the black it was a black
and it was the black only
there was nothing wrong with it it was
all okay
but what do they talk about optics
nowadays is that the word for things
that was a bad optic i thought yeah also
bad optics is referring to
it was a a black a black
i think people feel better when they
have control yeah
this is completely reasonable it's what
the substance is completely reasonable
i'm not saying this guy is a racist or
the racist but the way in which he talks
about a black and the black makes
makes me cringe it really does and this
is just again he's just a very there's
two sides to this guy he seems like a
very quirky strange guy singing songs
during the trial
doing jeopardy questions with people in
the crowd
um
freaking out and yelling at the cameras
about coverage on tele you know all
these just very very strange things and
then
there are also the alleged um
biases that are being ascribed to the
judge when it comes to evidence
standards depending on whether the
evidence is presented by the prosecution
or by the defense his evaluation of
different aspects of the trial and
questions to witnesses uh speculative
questions etc okay that's that's a whole
other thing but what a wacky guy
i am very much looking forward to when
this trial is done
and we can move on from it and we are
standing by for the verdict literally as
we speak we may be minutes from the
verdict we may be hours could be days
still to go we will see
one of our sponsors is splendid spoon
now if you're like me i love planning my
meals out for the week but sometimes i
just run out of time to plan them for
every single day and splendid spoon
makes that whole process a lot easier
they deliver fresh delicious plant-based
meals right to your door
ready to eat no cooking no cleaning
dishes saves you a lot of time you can
choose from over 50 hot and cold meal
options there's smoothies grain and
noodle bowls soups i'm a big soup guy
many of you know that i also really
liked the vegan meatballs with marinara
noodles delicious
both eye and splendid spoon believe
eating more plant-based is a great tool
for feeling good for helping the
environment the list goes on i'm not
vegan you all know that i think but
splendid spoon is really great to just
help me maximize the proportion of
plants in my diet splendid spoon takes
all of the work out of tasty healthy
plant-based meals and you'll save 35
dollars when you go to splendidspoon.com
pacman the link is down below